à l'occasion des collèges en musique le
collège des deux-canons accueillis pour
une matinée musicale bilon alix et son
groupe
un des objectifs visés et une rencontre
avec la création soutenant
l'apprentissage musical le département
facilite la mise en relation entre les
établissements volontaires et les
artistes originaires du quartier du
collège afin de sensibiliser ce jeune
public aux arts et à la culture
ben c'est une très bonne échange parce
que comme me dit toujours la culture et
l'éducation les indissociables dis ça
parce que grâce à la musique on peut
faire des calculs on peut lire on peut
apprendre à chanter moi on peut faire
plein de choses l'instrument pas
l'instrument fait part que du bruit et
donc on apprend aux jeunes ce que
l'instrument et mes voeux les jeunes
apprennent à lire va chanter à taper
dans les mers compter parce qu'il
comptait faut compter dans la musique
voilà est harmonieux et à pouvoir faire
les choses ensemble un épanouissement
musical mais aussi éducatif à travers
cet échange le département souhaite
faciliter l'accès à la culture aux
grands noms des réunionnais pour les
élèves
cette matinée est un moment privilégié
pour ces deux touchés réellement live
direct ici d'un spectacle gratuit avec
des très bons musiciens de voir en même
temps leurs collègues qui font de la
musique pour les nausées les musiciens
c'est extraordinaire je l'aï peuvent
jouer avec des professionnels ils
peuvent jouer devant leurs élèves donc
ça les valorise sur scène les élèves du
groupe de maloya du collège fi de ces
ont pu jouer avec les musiciens devant
leurs camarades avant de laisser place à
la chorale
des jeunes engagés qui se rendent une
fois par mois à l'hôpital des enfants de
saint denis pour leur offrir une après
midi récréative et musicale en juin pour
et avec eux une action possible suite à
la signature d'une convention entre le
département et l'hôpital invités à
participer à cette matinée des enfants y
ont ramené leurs propres instruments
aujourd'hui sommes si peu travaillé le
regard des autres c'est l'intégration
milieu ordinaire est aussi senti un peu
du contexte soignants comme aux enfants
qui sont perpétuellement dans le soin
dans la rééducation pour permettre un
temps d'évasion et de détente en
partenariat qu'il rencontrait d'autres
jeunes également s'inscrivant dans le
cadre du programme partagé la culture 14
collèges ont participé à cette cinquième
édition des collèges en musique